Hey, Will. Welcome to the show today. Thank you so much, man. Yeah. Do you ever want to be a guest on the show yourself? Oh man, what a privilege. Thank you for having me. What do you want to know? We don't have room. We're all booked. I just was wondering if that was ever a fantasy of yours. This is a great first question. It has always been. That's fine. Hey, let's start the show. Welcome to Smart List. I thought I was already on it. I've been listening to a lot of Duran Duran lately. Why, are you dating a 70 year old? Here we go. There it is. I have my search is Duran Duran, Life on Mars, David Bowie, Volcano Choir, Flaming Lips. Oh, Flaming Lips. I'm just saying it's eclectic, but Duran Duran lately has been really
嘿，威尔。欢迎来到今天的节目。非常感谢，老兄。不客气。你有没有想过自己也来节目当一次嘉宾？天哪，这真是一种特权。谢谢你们邀请我。你想知道什么？我们没位置了。我们已经约满了。我只是在想这是否一直是你的幻想。这是一个很好的第一个问题。一直都是。没关系。嘿，我们开始节目吧。欢迎来到《聪明笨蛋》。我以为我已经加入了。我最近一直在听杜然杜然（Duran Duran）的歌。为什么，你在和一个70岁的老人约会吗？我们开始吧。就是这样。我有我的搜索是杜然杜然、《火星生活》、大卫·鲍伊、火山合唱团、烈火红唇乐团。哦，烈火红唇乐团。我只是说这很折衷，但最近杜然杜然真的
getting me there. Really? Yeah. Where are you going? Are you taking like a step class or something? When I say where it's getting me, it's getting me to, as I explained, it's getting me to like a blazer with the sleeves pushed up. Yeah. Okay. And I'm just tapping on my steering wheel as I'm blazing through the hills. A little white powder. Are you cuffing your pants? And my pants are very baggy. They've got a nice pleat in them. Do you cuff them at the bottom? And I pop out, but my hair barely move. I got a nice one lock hanging down, but the mousse keeps it so tight. Yeah, mousse. Is that one lot go over one eye? What happened to mousse? I used to do so much hairspray in my hair. You couldn't
让我找到了感觉。真的吗？是的。你要去哪？你是要去上踏板操课还是别的什么？当我说它带给我的感觉时，它带给我的是，正如我所解释的，它带给我的是一种卷起袖子的西装外套的感觉。是的。好的。当我风驰电掣般穿过山丘时，我只是在方向盘上轻轻敲击。一点点白色的粉末。你在把裤脚卷起来吗？而且我的裤子非常宽松。它们上面有一个好看的褶子。你在底部把它们卷起来吗？我从车里蹦出来，但我的头发几乎没动。我有一缕好看的刘海垂在额前，但摩丝把它定得死死的。是的，摩丝。那一缕头发是垂在眼睛上一边吗？摩丝怎么了？我以前在头发上用过超级多的发胶。你甚至用
even move it with, I used a L'Oreal Spritz. No, you're going to get a box of it now. Yeah, here it comes. Here it comes. I don't know. It'll be tough to spray it through the baseball cap that you usually wear. I know. Look, it's even pretty tough now. You could be totally bald and just sew in a, just a rim of hair around the edge of your cap and no one would ever know because you'd never take off that hat. That's all I used to, my dad used to cut my hair. He literally just put a ball on my head and cut around it. Your dad, not your mom, huh? My mom always used to cut my hair. Oh yeah? Yeah. Hold your jokes. Hold your jokes. Yeah, I've seen the pictures. It's low level stuff. First of all, your impression
欧莱雅喷雾都无法让它动弹分毫。不，你现在得去买一盒了。对，它要来了。它要来了。我不知道。要把它喷在你平时戴的那顶棒球帽上可不容易。我知道。看，现在甚至都挺难的。你完全可以变成个光头，然后在帽子边缘缝上一圈假发，这样就没人知道了，因为你永远不会脱下那顶帽子。我以前用的就是这招，我爸以前给我理发。他简直就是把一个碗扣在我头上，然后沿着边缘剪。你爸，而不是你妈，哈？我妈以前总是给我理发。是吗？是的。省省你的笑话吧。省省你的笑话。是的，我看过那些照片。这水平可真够低的。首先，你对我的模仿
of me is really insulting. I sound like an idiot. You haven't seen the best of it. Yeah. I saw a picture of Jason today. Amanda, his wife and I were texting this morning early. On a chain, it should be pointed out on a chain, but the pictures is of Jason in his bedroom looking out the window, trying to look at my house from the window. We'll just had to downsize to a trailer. There's a dirt road about a mile from my house. I can see out my bedroom window and that's where he's going to park it. You can now see my house. What are you talking about? He's moving and I can actually see his house across like a mountain range from my bedroom window. Sean, in the middle of all this craziness. Yeah,
真的太侮辱人了。我听起来像个白痴。你还没见识到最精彩的呢。对。我今天看到了一张杰森的照片。阿曼达（他老婆）和我今天一早发了短信。在群聊里，应该指出是在群聊里，但照片是杰森在他的卧室里向窗外张望，试图从窗户看我的房子。我们刚不得不缩小居住规模换到了一辆拖车里。离我家大约有一英里远有一条泥土路。我从卧室窗户外能看到，他就要把车停在那儿。你现在能看到我家了。你在说什么呢？他搬家了，我实际上可以从我卧室的窗户隔着山脉看到他的房子。肖恩，在所有这些疯狂的事情当中。对，
you haven't even lived there very long. Well, four years, but like the crazy thing is in everything that's been going on that we've had a lot of stuff going on and we talk, we only talk like 12 times a day, the three of us. Yeah. And I forgot to mention to you over the last 30 times in the last 48 hours that I'm moving. Yeah. Wow. I didn't know that. That's crazy. But I honestly have always, one of my favorite movies is rear window and I saw it, I don't know what 20 years ago or something like that. And I've always thought about like, what would happen if you actually lived at a place where you could use a telescope to, to spot, like whenever I'm in New York, I'm amazed that people don't just stare across
你甚至在那里都没住多久。嗯，四年，但疯狂的是，在所有正在发生的事情中，我们有很多事情在发生，而且我们经常聊天，我们三个每天大概要聊12次。是的。而我忘了在过去48小时的30次通话中向你提过我要搬家了。是的。哇。我不知道这件事。这太疯狂了。但我老实说，我一直，我最喜欢的电影之一是《后窗》，我是大概20年前还是什么时候看过的。我一直都在想，如果你真的住在一个地方，可以用望远镜去，去观察——就像我每次在纽约时，我都对人们居然不盯着
at, into other people's window and just watch them all day long. How do you, like, well, you've lived in New York a lot. How are you comfortable living in a house or an apartment without the shades down 100% of the time? Well, where I, where I lived in New York the last 10 years, there was no other building right there. So I was lucky in that way, but I love that your instinct is like, you're trying to figure out how to hold yourself back from looking into people. I want to know what power telescope I need to keep an eye on you and gather information. Literally the photo that Amanda took is Jason doesn't even know he's staring at the window. So I got that to look for gauging distance. Well, so it's
对面别人的窗户，整天看着他们感到大为惊奇。你怎么能——比如，你经常在纽约生活。你怎么能忍在百叶窗100%不拉下的情况下住在一个房子或公寓里呢？嗯，我在纽约过去10年住的地方，正对面没有别的建筑。所以在这一点上我很幸运，但我喜欢你的直觉，就像你在拼命克制自己不去窥视别人一样。我想知道我需要什么功率的望远镜才能盯着你并收集情报。说实话，阿曼达拍的那张照片里，杰森甚至都不知道他正盯着窗户看。所以我得找个东西来测算距离。好吧，所以现在
very early and it's got to be because of our damn surprise guest must have something pressing later on. And that's why we're up early recording this. Let's get to it. Everybody looks great by the way for this, for this morning. Real puffy in the morning. I'm still wiping that sleep on my ass. It's not true. All right, gang, today's guest is one of America's great combos. Okay. He was as much of a print journalist as he is a current on air one. He's Ivy League educated, but is also a down and dirty jock. What? He owns three cats, but is highly allergic. He thinks the world is flat, but has an impressive collection of globes. He grew up around Detroit's auto industry, but rides a bike exclusively. He despises jazz, but was named after the
时间还很早，这肯定是因为我们该死的神秘嘉宾待会儿一定有什么紧要的事。这就是为什么我们这么早就起来录音了。我们开始吧。顺便说一句，大家今天早上的气色看起来都很棒。早上脸肿得厉害。我还得揉掉眼屎呢。这不是真的。好吧，各位，今天的嘉宾是美国伟大的多面手之一。好。他既是一位纸媒记者，也是一位当红的电视直播记者。他受过常春藤盟校的教育，但也是个接地气的狂热体育迷。什么？他养了三只猫，但严重过敏。他认为世界是平的，却收藏了令人印象深刻的地球仪。他在底特律的汽车工业环境中长大，但只骑自行车。他鄙视爵士乐，却以
world's famous jazz drummer. He claims to be the writer of a new book about the odds of meeting your soulmate at a disco called Devil May Dance. And he's the current host of CNN State of the Union America. This is Jake Tapper. Jake Tapper. Yeah. Is all that true? Very little. Very little of what you said is true. Very little of that's true. I do have a book called Devil May Dance, but it's not about meeting your soulmate at a disco. Is it not? Let's read the first chapter. Let's read the first chapter. Actually, it might be up your alley. It's about Hollywood and the Rat Pack in 1962. Oh, I would like that. Oh, that's Jason Zara. Can we have a free option on it right now? Did you say free? We're just
世界著名的爵士鼓手命名。他自称是一本关于在名为“恶魔可能跳舞”的迪斯科舞厅遇到灵魂伴侣几率的新书的作者。他目前是CNN《国情咨文》节目的主持人。这就是杰克·塔珀（Jake Tapper）。杰克·塔珀。对。所有这些都是真的吗？很少。你刚才说的很少是真的。那些几乎没有真的。我确实有一本叫《恶魔可能跳舞》的书，但它不是关于在迪斯科舞厅遇到灵魂伴侣的。不是吗？让我们读第一章。让我们读第一章。其实，这可能很合你的胃口。它是关于1962年的好莱坞和鼠党（Rat Pack）的。哦，我会喜欢这个。哦，那是杰森·扎拉。我们现在能买下它的免费改编权吗？你刚才说免费吗？我们只是
going to shop it around. You can have the episode one free as long as there's a 10 episode commitment and it's through your Netflix deal. Wow. Look at this guy. Is it fiction or nonfiction? It's fiction. It's fiction. Jake, have you done the, did you do the audio record for the book on tape? The first one in the series, I did the audio and then the second one they hired a professional. Professional. Oh yeah. You got fired from your own book read. Wow. That's tough. I did. Well, you know, the thing is also the first one has a lot of characters from history. The first one takes place in 1954 has a lot of characters from history. And I did attempt to do the voices. Oh, you did? I did. I don't know if they, maybe they
打算拿它到处推销。只要承诺拍10集并且通过你们的Netflix合约，第一集就可以免费。哇。看看这家伙。这是小说还是非小说？是小说。是小说。杰克，你有没有为有声书录音？系列中的第一本，我录了音频，然后第二本他们雇了一个专业人士。专业人士。哦，对。你被自己的书开除，不让你读了。哇。这太惨了。我确实是。不过，你知道，第一本有很多历史人物。第一本发生在1954年，里面有很多历史人物。我确实尝试过去模仿那些声音。哦，你试过？我试过。我不知道他们，也许他们
didn't like that. Maybe they give us a taste. Let's hear. Let's hear. Well, there's Robert Kennedy who's really, he's got a higher voice and then there's John F. Kennedy, which is a deeper kind of more, slightly more refined. That's pretty good. Not terrible. Not, I'm no, I'm no will or not, but it's, I didn't think it was horrible. No, that is very good. So are you fascinated with that, that era? I mean, what, why did you? The whole, yeah, the fifties and the sixties up until the free love generation starts. Yeah, because it's this really, it looks so romantic and it is completely menacing and awful, but it looks fashionable and lovely with the, with the martinis and the bourbon and the smoking and
不喜欢那样。也许给我们露一手。让我们听听。让我们听听。嗯，有罗伯特·肯尼迪，他的声音真的，他的声音更高，然后是约翰·F·肯尼迪，声音更低沉一些，稍微更温文尔雅一点。这挺不错的。不赖。不，我不是什么威尔·阿奈特，但我觉得它，我不认为这有多糟糕。不，这非常好。那么，你对那个时代很着迷吗？我是说，你为什么会……整个，对，50年代和60年代，一直到自由恋爱时代开始。是的，因为这真的很，它看起来如此浪漫，而且它完全是来势汹汹且糟糕透顶，但伴随着马提尼、波本威士忌和香烟，它看起来时髦又可爱，
everyone looks stylish. And it was like the birth of, of, of what we do now, basically it feels like. Yeah. Is there a current equivalent to that? Do you think like what, what area it doesn't even, what industry, like where, where are the cool sort of martini swelling may be associated with, with, with organized crime group of fancy pants is. Biomedicine. It's all biomedicine. Are they having the swanky parties in the pharmaceutical world? The menace is all reported on now. Whereas back then it was like, Oh, isn't that funny Sinatra's hanging out with a mobster? Right. And you can't really prove it nowadays. You can get pretty close to it. Yeah. Yeah. Now, where do you find time to sit and write a
每个人看起来都很有型。而且它感觉就像我们现在所做的事的诞生，基本上是这样。是的。现在有没有与之相当的事物？你觉得像什么领域，甚至不需要是什么行业，比如那些举办时髦马提尼派对、可能与有组织犯罪团伙或时髦人士有关的地方在哪里？生物医学。全都是生物医学。他们在制药界举办豪华派对吗？现在的威胁都是公开报道的了。而在当年，情况就像是，“哦，弗兰克·辛纳屈和黑帮混在一起，这不是很搞笑吗？”没错。而且你现在真的无法证明这一点。你可以查得很接近。对。对。现在，当你必须了解地球上发生的一切最新动态时，你从哪里找到时间坐下来写一部
novel when you are having to stay up to date with everything around the planet? And, and that is that, that's a, and that's literal. Yeah, that's true. That's an accurate statement by you. Do you have, do you have a staff of thousands of people that, that, that just tell you what to say every day and you're like a robot and you know nothing about world politics. And there's nothing in between these two options. Right. Yeah. You're just a dumb novelist and, and they put this copy in front of you. I'm just one of the two. I do have an amazing staff for my show, my daily show on CNN and my Sunday show. They're amazing staff, but no, I'm not just reading what they put in front of me. That's not accurate.
小说？而且，而且那是，那是字面意义上的。是的，那是真的。你这句话很准确。你是不是有一支成千上万人的员工队伍，每天告诉你该说什么，你就像个机器人，对世界政治一无所知？而且这两种选择之间没有中间状态。对。是的。你只是个愚蠢的小说家，他们把这些稿子摆在你面前。我只是其中之一。我的节目——我在CNN的日常节目和周日节目——确实有一支了不起的团队。他们是很棒的团队，但不是的，我不只是在照读他们摆在我面前的东西。那并不准确。
Yeah. Because like when I was a kid, I ran, I ran into my algebra teacher at the Kmart and I was like, Oh my God, that's, I just picture you inside your TV, never doing anything else other than journalism. Yeah. I'll tell you something. Writing the book was a great escape from the real world. The fiction diving into fiction and writing about the rat pack and Sinatra and the Kennedys was a big relief and a big escape from covering the world as it was while I was writing it. But I'm literally curious, I'm curious about where you'd literally find the time. My rule is if, if you're writing, if you have a writing project, if you write at least 15 minutes a day, then you, everybody can find 15 minutes a day. But you don't need
是的，因为就像我小时候，我在Kmart碰到了我的代数老师，我就想，天哪，那就是——我脑海里的画面一直是你待在电视机里面，除了做新闻什么都不做。嗯，我告诉你一件事。写书是逃离现实世界的一个绝佳途径。沉浸在小说中，写写鼠党、辛纳屈和肯尼迪，这是一个极大的解脱，也是从我写作时不断报道的现实世界中逃离出来的好方法。但我真的很好奇，我好奇你到底从哪儿挤出时间。我的规则是，如果你在写作，如果你每天至少写15分钟，那么每个人都能抽出15分钟。但你不需要
an hour to get into that 15 minutes of, of, of space. Like you can change gears that quickly, but also the 15 minutes needs to actually be writing, not just thinking. It can't be goofing around. Jason needs a couple hours in the trailer before he starts getting into Marty, you know, when he, when he gets on the Ozark, he needs two hours in the trailer, an hour to yell at the assistant and then an hour to put on his hair. And then he's, and then he's Marty. An hour to put on his hair. Yeah. Well, no, I got one with a zipper now. So I cut in half. That's your sport piece. Jake, let me ask you this. I've always wondered, so you do your show every day. What is that? Because as Jason said, you have to be up on
一个小时来进入那15分钟的创作状态。你可以转换得那么快，而且这15分钟必须是真正的写作，而不仅仅是思考。不能是在瞎胡闹。杰森在开始演马蒂之前需要在拖车里待上好几个小时，你知道的，当他出演《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）时，他需要在拖车里待两个小时，一个小时用来对助手吼叫，一个小时用来弄头发。然后他才是，然后他才是马蒂。花一个小时弄头发。是的。好吧，不，我现在买了个带拉链的。所以我把它缩短了一半。那是你的运动假发。杰克，让我问你这个。我一直很好奇，所以你每天都要做节目。那是什么样的？因为正如杰森所说，你必须随时了解
everything. So you're constantly downloading information. You're constantly getting stuff in real time. I imagine quicker than we are because you're, you're right in the, at the, at the center of the, you know, the nerve center of news worldwide. So what, what does your day look like? Like before we see you on air, how much before that are you in the office and are you engaged the moment you wake up? Is it a 24 seven engagement in what you do? It feels like it must be. Yes. There's a 24 seven engagement about stories and what's going on and what we're planning for. Like for instance, I was just, I just got an email from my executive producer about stories that we have in the pipeline stories that I'm
一切。所以你不断地下载信息。你不断地实时接收各种信息。我想比我们更快，因为你正处于，处于世界新闻神经中枢的中心。那么，你的一天是怎样的？在我们看到你上镜之前，你提前多久去办公室？从你醒来的那一刻起你就投入其中了吗？这似乎是一个全天候24小时连轴转的工作。感觉一定是的。是的。这是一个关于新闻报道、正在发生的事情以及我们正在计划的事情的24小时不间断的关注。比如，我刚刚收到执行制片人的一封邮件，关于我们正在筹备的报道、我正在分配的报道。
assigning. Um, he wanted to be kept more in the loop, which is understandable. Um, cause you know, I'm just like sending notes to people like, this is a good story. You should do it. And then they come back to my executive producer. Here's the story. And he's like, what, what is this? What do you, what do you, I don't understand what this is. And then, and do you, are you obligated since you're, you're one of the main anchors at one of the main news sources around the main anchor at the main anchor of the world. Great adjustment. Great adjustment. Yeah. It's better, better said. The world's anchor. Um, are you obligated to go to a committee for lack of a better word to decide what leads and what
他希望随时了解更多情况，这是可以理解的，因为你知道，我只是给人们发便签：“这是一个好故事，你应该做这个。”然后他们又回到我的执行制片人那里：“这是这个故事。”然后他说：“什么，这是什么？你，你是什么意思，我不明白这是什么。”然后，既然你是各大新闻源中主要的主播之一——世界的主棒——绝佳的调整。绝佳的调整。是的，说得更好，世界的主播。你有义务去向一个委员会（姑且这么叫）汇报，来决定什么作头条，什么不作头条，
doesn't because that can affect the national discussion, which could affect the priorities of policy because it's in the zeitgeist more like, do you feel a responsibility to, to decide what leads and what is at the end of the show, giving, assigning importance to certain issues? Um, the, there's a morning, uh, call with my executive producer where we talk about what we think will lead. No, obviously at eight 30 in the morning, you know, what is going to lead at four o'clock and five o'clock for our two hours, um, might change. But you know, here's what we're thinking of today based on the schedule of the day and based on what's happening. Then there's a morning editorial call where the executives
因为这会影响全国的讨论，进而可能影响政策的优先事项，因为它更多地存在于时代精神之中——比如说，你是否感到有责任去决定什么作头条、什么放在节目末尾，从而赋予某些议题以重要性？嗯，早上会和我的执行制片人有一个晨会，我们讨论我们认为什么会成为头条。当然，早上8点半的时候，你知道下午4点和5点我们两小时的节目里什么会成为头条，这可能会变。但你知道，根据当天的日程安排和正在发生的事情，这就是我们今天的想法。然后是一个早上的编辑会议，高管们
share their views of what are the most important stories and what are important elements of those stories. And then, um, and then it's really up to us, me and my, and my team. Yeah. What is that process? I would be burdened by the, uh, responsibility of directly sort of implying, uh, what is more important than another thing? And how do you gauge that? How do you, how do you just, that is the big challenge of being an anchor and running a show is like, what do you lead with? What do you, it's really more, what do you leave out? Because as long as you tell a story of like, as long as, oh, this happened with veterans today, I want to cover this, but it doesn't necessarily have to lead the broadcast, but
分享他们对哪些是最重要新闻以及这些新闻中哪些是重要元素的看法。然后，然后这真的取决于我们，我和我的团队。是的。这个过程是怎样的？我会被那种直接暗示什么比什么更重要的责任感给压垮的。你是如何权衡这一点的？你是怎么做到这一点的——这正是作为主播和管理节目的巨大挑战所在：你以什么作为头条？你以什么——其实更是：你遗漏了什么？因为只要你讲述了一个故事，比如“今天退伍军人发生了这件事，我想报道它”，它不一定非得作为广播的头条，但它在这一小时或两小时内。
it's in the hour or the two hours. But that said, the stories you leave out are the ones that are, that are the heartbreaks and you're right. It's tough. Are you ever put in a position where somebody reaches out or how often are you put in the position where people reach out, people who are like Jason says, potentially policymakers, politicians, et cetera, who, who are reaching out to you and saying, Hey, you should be covering this in order to serve their own, uh, their own needs. Does that occur? Do you have, do you get those calls where people, cause they, they realize the power that you have? Meaning if I called you up and I said, Jake, you need to be covering more about me.
话虽如此，你遗漏的故事才是那些让人心碎的故事，你说得对，这很难。你有没有遇到过这样的情况：有人联系你，或者你多久会遇到一次这种情况——像杰森所说的那样，潜在的决策者、政治家等联系你，说：“嘿，你应该报道这个，”以此来服务于他们自己的需求？这种情况会发生吗？你会接到这样的电话吗，因为他们意识到你所拥有的权力？意思是如果我给你打电话说：“杰克，你需要更多地报道我，”
I want you to lead every hour with stuff about me to keep me in the conversation, which by the way, is reasonable. That's a completely reasonable price and my passion, my passion, by the way, is Duran Duran, but if you could, We got it. Yeah, I know you're hungry like the wolf. Does that, does that, but Jason is the wolf. Do you, Teen, Teen, Teen, I saw that in the theater, by the way. Two, two, no. I saw that in the theater. I saw a Teen Wolf.
“我希望你每个小时的头条都是关于我的内容，好让我留在公众视野中。”顺便说一句，这很合理。这完全是一个合理的价格，我的热情，顺便说一句，是杜然杜然，但如果你能——我们懂了。是的，我知道你像饿狼一样渴望。这会不会——但杰森才是那只狼。你，听，听，听，我以前在电影院看过那个。二，二，没有。我在电影院看过。我看过《狼人少年2》（Teen Wolf Too）。
I appreciate your cash. Teen Wolf two. Jake, Jake, you'll know that years ago, we used to, Jason and I and Sean played in this card game with Kyle Gass, uh, one half of Tenacious D for, for many years until we all lost too much money. But, uh, Jason's To Kyle. Jason's Nickname was T Dub as in Teen Wolf and he was, that's a great nickname. By the way, may I ask, is there a scene in Teen Wolf? And I haven't seen it since Two.
我很感激你的现金。《狼人少年2》。杰克，你会知道，几年前，我和杰森还有肖恩跟凯尔·加斯（Kyle Gass，摇滚乐队Tenacious D的成员之一）一起玩过这种纸牌游戏，玩了很多年，直到我们都输了太多钱。但是，杰森的——凯尔。杰森的外号叫T Dub，就像《狼人少年》里的那样，他当时——那是个很棒的外号。顺便问一下，在《狼人少年2》里有没有这么一个场景——自从第二部以后我就没看过这电影了——
When did it come out? Already loving the area. Sorry. Teen Wolf two. I apologize. Teen Wolf two. It's worth a rewatch. Michael J. Fox was in the first. Jason was in the second. Teen Wolf two. Did that come out in 86, 85? I want to say 87 because that's the year I didn't graduate high school because I was working long hours on T Dub, T Dub two.
它是哪一年上映的？我已经开始爱上这个片场了。抱歉。《狼人少年2》。我道歉。《狼人少年2》。值得重温一遍。迈克尔·J·福克斯演了第一部。杰森演了第二部。《狼人少年2》。那是86年还是85年上映的？我想说是87年，因为那年我没有高中毕业，因为我花了很多时间在拍摄《T Dub 2》上。
T Dub T. Really? Yeah. T Dub T. T Dub T. Is there a scene in that where you're in the locker room and you look down and you have an incredibly long chest air and you're like, what the hell is this? Or is that T Dub one? No, no, it was T Dub two and we had to cut it. Uh, you may have seen it on the, uh, the DVD extras. We had to cut it because of its, uh, um, unclassy, uh, sexual implications.
T Dub T。真的吗？是的。T Dub T。T Dub T。里面有没有这样一个场景：你在更衣室里，低头一看，发现自己胸前长了一根极其浓密的胸毛，然后你说：“这到底是什么鬼？”或者那是《狼人少年1》里的？不，不，那是《狼人少年2》，而且我们不得不把它剪掉了。你可能在DVD花絮里看到过它。因为它的，呃，不太优雅的性暗示，我们不得不把它剪掉。
Wait, wait a second. You just established that Jake is really busy and you think he's watching the DVD extras on T Dub? Yeah. No, he's got, he could manage his day. We established that. That was definitely the original print because I, no offense, I've only seen the film once in a theater. So maybe at the Ballokinwood Pennsylvania movie theater, there was an errant copy, a secret unedited version. It was because of that screening. They cut it.
等一下，等一下。你刚才已经确定杰克真的很忙，而你觉得他在看《T Dub》的DVD花絮？对。不，他能掌控自己的一天。我们已经确认过了。那绝对是原始版本，因为我——说句得罪的话——我在电影院只看过一次这电影。所以也许在宾夕法尼亚州巴洛金伍德的电影院里，有一份漏网的拷贝，一个秘密的未剪辑版本。就是因为那场放映。他们把它剪掉了。
This dovetails nicely into my next question pulled from your Wikipedia page. Um, you're, uh, you dabbled with, uh, the idea of maybe going into the entertainment industry while you were at SC studying cinematic fine arts. That's true. I went to Dartmouth and then after Dartmouth, I went to the USC graduate school and film and I did one semester there and what, what happened? What did you fire yourself from that too? Um, there were a number of things that happened. One of them was I found Los Angeles, uh, an incredibly isolating bleak place.
这与我从你的维基百科页面上摘录的下一个问题完美契合。嗯，你在南加州大学（USC）学习电影美术时，曾涉足过进入娱乐行业的想法。千真万确。我去了达特茅斯，达特茅斯毕业后，我去了南加州大学电影研究生院，我在那里读了一个学期，然后呢？发生了什么？你把自己从那个学校也开除啦？呃，发生了很多事情。其中之一是我发现洛杉矶是一个极其孤立、荒凉的地方。
Oh my God. Thank you for joining us today, Jake. Thank you. Well, maybe if I had been hanging out with you, Jason, maybe if you were my friend then I would have. Yeah. I mean, we could have been like partying with Dana Plato and Quinn Cummings. He was a very fair weather friend back in those days. You're lucky you didn't know him. I get it that Los Angeles is a tricky place to find your, uh, your, your tribe.
天哪。谢谢你今天加入我们，杰克。谢谢。好吧，也许如果我和你混在一起，杰森，也许如果你那时是我的朋友，我就会了。是的。我的意思是，我们可以和达娜·普拉托（Dana Plato）和奎因·卡明斯（Quinn Cummings）一起去派对。他当年可真是个见风使舵的朋友。你真幸运没认识他。我理解洛杉矶是个很难找到志同道合之人的棘手地方。
The truth is I was sitting in film production class listening to the Clarence Thomas hearings on my yellow Sony Walkman and I thought to myself, maybe I'm more interested in something else than I am in film and also the film production producer left the class in the middle of the semester to go, I think he was the DP on Harlem nights. Oh my God. Wow. But, uh, you're kind of tangentially, uh, involved since your incredible books are, uh, at least one that I know was made into a movie what last year, yes, the outpost. That's a nonfiction
事实是，我当时正坐在电影制作课上，用我黄色的索尼随身听听着克拉伦斯·托马斯（Clarence Thomas）的听证会，我心里想：也许我对别的东西比对电影更感兴趣。而且电影制作课的制作人在学期中途离开了班级，去——我猜他是《哈莱姆之夜》（Harlem Nights）的摄影指导。天哪。哇。但是，你有点间接地参与其中，因为你那几本不可思议的书——至少我知道的一本去年被改编成了电影，对吧？是的，《法外之地》（The Outpost）。那是一本关于阿富汗的纪实
book about Afghanistan that was made into a film by Rod Lurie starring Caleb Landry-Jones and Orlando Bloom and, and Scotty's good. And they did a great job. Yeah. Did you get on set? Were you involved at all in sort of the, the creative? Yeah. I was an executive producer and I went to Bulgaria to visit the set. Um, and it was an interesting experience. Did you enjoy it? A lot of Bulgarians. More than you'd think. More than you'd think. More than you'd think. A lot of Bulgarians
书籍，被罗德·鲁瑞（Rod Lurie）改编成了一部电影，由卡莱布·兰德里·琼斯（Caleb Landry-Jones）、奥兰多·布鲁姆（Orlando Bloom）主演，而且斯科蒂演得很好。他们做得很好。是的。你去片场了吗？你是否以某种方式参与了创意工作？是的。我是执行制片人，我去保加利亚访问了片场。那是一次有趣的体验。你喜欢吗？有很多保加利亚人。比你想象的要多。比你想象的要多。比你想象的要多。有很多保加利亚人
there. Were you involved in like, uh, uh, kind of writing the script or looking or playing around with editing or giving creative notes on set? Like how involved did you get? I was more involved in, um, being a conduit between, because it's a real story, being a conduit between the people making the movie and the people who the movie's about. Right. Um, you know, I would offer notes. I saw early versions of the film. Um, there was a whole decision that the book takes place over a course of four years. Uh, and the movie is
在那里。你有参与写剧本、审阅剧本、参与剪辑或在片场提出创意意见之类的工作吗？你参与得有多深？我更多地参与了——因为这是一个真实的故事——在制作电影的人和电影所讲述的人物之间充当桥梁。对。你知道的，我会提出意见。我看过电影的早期版本。有一个整体的决定——这本书跨越了四年的时间，而电影
really focused just on like the last month. Right. And there was a whole kind of controversial decision within the community of the people who actually served there about whether or not we should, whether or not people from earlier years could, their stories could be told in the same narrative, even though they never actually served together. Right. How much latitude could you take with, with, with, yeah. Exactly.
实际上只聚焦于最后一个月。对。在实际在那里服役的人员社区中，产生了一个充满争议的决定：我们是否应该、早期几年的人的故事是否应该被讲进同一个叙事中，尽管他们从未真正在一起服役过。对。你可以在多大程度上进行艺术加工？是的。完全正确。
So I was part of that. What's that responsibility like to, when you're telling a story like that where the stakes are very high and you're telling very personal stories of people who are in really, uh, intense life, I don't even know how to say it, you know, just things that were, you know, stakes couldn't be higher. What, what is that? Like, do you feel a sort of a burden to, in that way, to really tell, make sure that your story reflects what actually happened and served all the people who, who, you know, sacrificed, et cetera. It's a great question. And the truth is I, I'd burdens not the word for it, but I had,
所以我参与了那部分。当你讲述这样一个利害攸关、并且讲述了那些身处极度紧张（我甚至不知道该怎么说，你知道，就是那些事情……）生活中的人们的极其个人的故事时，那种责任感是什么样的？利害关系再高不过了。那是什么感觉？你是否觉得有一种负担，要以那种方式真正讲述故事，确保你的故事反映了实际发生的事情，并服务于所有那些（你知道的）做出牺牲的人们？这是一个很好的问题。说实话，“负担”这个词并不是很贴切，但我确实有，
it was an immense responsibility and we took it very, very seriously. We even had like an early screening and flew people who had lost family members at the outpost to Washington DC to see an early cut of the film. It was almost done. Uh, there were some special effects that weren't in there yet, but it was almost fully completed. And I was a wreck. I was an absolute wreck because I didn't know, I mean, I'd seen the movie and I knew how I felt about it, which is I thought it told the story respectfully and somberly. It wasn't gratuitous, but it also didn't whitewash what happened and the like in, you know, and there were some liberties taken in terms of near, in terms of the timing, the time people who served in 2006 were put
这是一种巨大的责任，我们非常非常认真地对待它。我们甚至还搞了一场早期试映，把在前方基地失去亲人的家属飞到华盛顿特区观看电影的早期剪辑版。它几乎完成了。有一些特效还没加上，但已经基本完成了。我当时崩溃了。我完全崩溃了，因为我不知道——我的意思是，我看过这部电影，我知道我自己的感受，那就是我认为它以尊重和严肃的方式讲述了这个故事。它没有刻意煽情，但也没有粉饰发生的事情，而且（你知道的）在时间安排上做了一些艺术处理，2006年服役的人被放进了2009年的叙事中，但总的来说，它相当地
in the narrow of it in 2009, but generally speaking, it was pretty, uh, accurate. And, but I was terrified because, you know, A, I've never served. So I didn't know it was going to be like for the veterans to see this be, I, the people who had lost family members, I wondered like, what are they going to feel like watching? You know, in the case of Ken and Beth Keating, whose son Ben Keating was killed in Afghanistan and the combat combat outpost was named after him, they're going to watch Orlando Bloom play their son. What's that experience like? And then they're going to watch Orlando Bloom as their son die. What's that experience going to be like? Like, so, but ultimately it was very, uh, it was more
准确。但我吓坏了，因为，A，我从来没有服过兵役。所以我不知道退伍军人们看到这一切会作何感想，那些失去亲人的家属，我想知道：他们看的时候会是什么感觉？（你知道，以肯和贝思·基廷为例，他们的儿子本·基廷在阿富汗牺牲，前哨战斗基地就是以他的名字命名的。）他们将看着奥兰多·布鲁姆扮演他们的儿子。那会是怎样的体验？然后他们将看着奥兰多·布鲁姆扮演的他们的儿子死去。那又会是怎样的体验？所以——但最终，这比什么都更像是一种解脱。
of a relief than, than anything else. But afterwards we went to each family member. I walked around and, and every one of them thought that the film had been fair and respectful and they were honored. Oh, that's great. Did you feel that same responsibility, Sean, in Three Stooges? Yeah, I did. Thank you, Will. I went to the families of the descendants of the Three Stooges and, uh, What are they? Did they poke you in the eye? Yeah. Let's talk about Body Slam, the Jesse Ventura story published in 1999.
但事后我们走近每一位家属。我四处走动，他们每个人都认为这部电影是公平和尊重的，他们感到很荣幸。哦，太棒了。肖恩，你在《三个臭皮匠》（The Three Stooges）里也感受到那种责任感了吗？是的，我有。谢谢你，威尔。我去找了《三个臭皮匠》后代的家族，然后——他们怎么样？他们戳你的眼睛了吗？对。我们来谈谈1999年出版的《重摔：杰西·文图拉的故事》（Body Slam: The Jesse Ventura Story）。
My first book. Yeah. What drew you to the story of Jesse Ventura? I mean, he's certainly an interesting guy, but, uh, was there one thing that was like, hang on. I need to, uh, really get in the cave on this one. I would say Body Slam is probably the Teen Wolf two of my career. No, you should be so lucky. They came with a check and I needed some work. Yeah. It's the check part that was minus in mine. Look, I, I had done some writing about sports and I was a, I worked for Washington city paper a free weekly in DC and a publisher came to me and said, you know, Jesse Ventura
我的第一本书。是的。是什么吸引你关注杰西·文图拉的故事？我的意思是，他当然是个有趣的人，但有没有那么一件事让你觉得：“等等，我需要深入研究一下这个。”我会说《重摔》可能是我职业生涯中的《狼人少年2》。不，你可真走运。他们带着支票来了，而我当时需要一些工作。是的。支票部分才是我没有的。听着，我以前写过一些体育方面的文章，我曾在华盛顿自由周报（Washington City Paper）工作过，那是华盛顿特区的一份免费周刊，有个出版商找到我说：“你知道，杰西·文图拉
was just elected. They, they need somebody to, to do a book and they need it done in two months or something like that. How old were you when you've got your first on-camera journalist job? On-camera, like paid journals job, 30, you know, were you doing some amateur stuff before? Uh, in the valley, just some, uh, it was, uh, CNN. Actually, I had a, Hey, so what's CNN? Yeah. It was a, it was a show called take five where five young pundits sat around and talked
刚刚当选。他们需要有人写一本书，而且他们需要在两个月左右的时间里搞定。”你获得第一份摄像机前的记者工作时多大？在摄像机前，也就是有薪的记者工作，30岁，你之前做过一些业余的工作吗？在山谷（The Valley），只是一些——那是——CNN。其实，我有一个——嘿，那CNN是什么？是的。那是一个叫《Take 5》的节目，五个年轻的专家坐在一起谈论
about the news and they put it on, they put it, uh, the time slot was exactly when young people want to watch young pundits talking about the news Saturday night at 8 30. Oh man. Sure. Yeah. That's what all the cool kids are watching. That's when young people are watching TV, looking for news. I love, by the way, any, any time you use the term young people, you're immediately not hitting that demographic.
新闻，然后他们把它播出来——播出的时间段正是年轻人最想看年轻专家谈论新闻的时候：周六晚上8点半。天哪。当然。是的。这正是所有酷炫的孩子们都在看的。那是年轻人看电视寻找新闻的时候。顺便说一句，我喜欢任何时候你使用“年轻人”这个词，你立刻就无法触及那个目标受众。
Yeah. Hello, fellow young people. Was that thrilling? Was it like I've arrived? This is what I wanted to do. No, it was, no, because I was still a full-time print journalist and it was just like, this is interesting. This is fun. This is interesting. I'm sure it's all super cringe. Who, who are your co-hosts? Um, again, it was a show by committee, like a camel as an animal by committee. So it's take five. So it's five people. Great.
是的。嗨，同龄的年轻人。那是令人兴奋的吗？是不是有一种“我成功了，这就是我想做的事”的感觉？不，不是的，不，因为我仍然是一个全职的纸媒记者，感觉就像：这很有趣。这挺好玩的。这挺有意思的。我敢肯定这一切都超级尴尬。谁，谁是你的联合主持人？嗯，同样，这是一个由委员会运营的节目，就像一头由委员会设计出来的骆驼。所以它叫《Take 5》。所以有五个人。太棒了。
Uh, the, the, it was me, Michelle Cottle, who now writes for the New York Times, Robert George, who now writes for the New York Daily News. And then for the other two slots, they were rotating seats. Each seat had four people that rotated within them. You just put them like on a spinning, kind of like a, there was like a lazy Susan. Lazy Susan, yeah. It was more like, um, the prices right where you They bring them down. Yeah.
呃，那里面有我、现在为《纽约时报》写作的米歇尔·科特尔（Michelle Cottle）、现在为《纽约每日新闻》写作的罗伯特·乔治（Robert George）。至于另外两个位置，它们是轮流坐的座位。每个座位都有四个人轮流坐。你们就像是把他们放在一个旋转的——有点像懒人盘（Lazy Susan）。懒人盘，对。更像是，呃，《价格猜猜猜》（The Price Is Right），他们把人带下来。对。
And like who's going to, who's going to show up and, oh, How did that not survive? John Dickerson. How long was that on? Six months. Uh-huh. It's quite a run. Six months. And our last show, I believe was on September 8th, 2001.
就像谁会出场，哦，那怎么没活下来？约翰·迪克森（John Dickerson）。那节目播了多久？六个月。嗯。真是一段不短的旅程。六个月。而我们的最后一期节目，我相信是在2001年9月8日。
Oh my gosh. Wow. Oh my gosh. And then we were all waiting to find out if it was going to get renewed. Sure. Yeah. And then something happened in the intervening days that made the show seem rather, rather trifling.
哦天哪。哇。哦天哪。然后我们都在等消息，看它会不会续订。当然。是的。然后在这期间发生了一些事情，让这个节目看起来相当、相当微不足道。
Yeah. And so, uh, Jake, you enjoy, you enjoy now that once you dabbled in that, uh, and on camera thing now you really enjoy it. And it's something. I love it. I love it. You love it. Do the news.
所以，呃，杰克，你现在很享受，一旦你涉足了那个领域，那个在镜头前的事情，现在你真的很享受它。这是某种——我喜欢它。我喜欢它。你很喜欢。做新闻。
And I love, and what the stuff I love is, um, here's a brilliant reporter who just spent a week in Myanmar and here's her story about the coup there and like how oppressed the people there. And here's nine minutes. Watch it. Right. And people have been pretty good. They've been watching it.
我喜欢，我喜欢的是——这里有一位出色的记者，刚刚在缅甸呆了一个星期，这里是她关于当地政变以及当地人民受到多大压迫的报道，这里有九分钟。看一看。对。人们表现得挺不错的。他们一直在看。
And so it's been exciting. Right. I mean, you're genuine, sincere interest in, in all of these things. Uh, it is infectious. I do, I do. And I love your stick to it. Of this one, when, when, uh, when people try to wiggle off the hook, you keep them on it and you, you, you see if they've got two or three answers to that same question or
所以这很令人兴奋。对。我的意思是，你对所有这些事情的真诚、发自内心的兴趣，是具有传染性的。我是真的。我确实如此。我喜欢你的坚持不懈。当人们试图金蝉脱壳时，你让他们继续留在原地，你看看他们对同一个问题是否有两三个回答，
if they just been perhaps with one retort. And whether people think it or not about the separation that has been kind of put out there of Fox news is only Republican CNN is only, you know, left and, uh, which has always been such a misnomer. Yeah. You, you, you, I don't think of us as left. No, right. I think of the MSNBC, but I know what you're saying there.
或者他们是否可能只有一个反驳。不管人们怎么认为——关于那种已经被炒作出来的分离，即福克斯新闻只代表共和党，CNN只代表左翼，而这历来是一个用词不当的说法。是的。你，你——我不认为我们是左翼。不，对。我认为MSNBC是，但我知道你在说什么。
Yeah. No, no, no, but you, but you within CNN, to me are truly center. You really, truly think about both sides. You report the truth. It's not what you said before. It's not what you said before the show. Before the show. What did I say?
不，不，不，但你在CNN内部，在我看来真的是中间派。你真的真诚地考虑双方。你报道真相。这不是你之前说的。不是节目开始前说的。我之前说什么了？
We weren't recording that part though. You said, no, no. We'll not. The truth is I don't, I don't think either party has all the answers and, and, and, and I just, I'd be really honestly don't. So when governor Newsom, when your governor came on the show, I asked him some tough questions about that, uh, ill-fated meal he had. Did you ever get him to admit that he needed to sweep the forest and rake them up?
不过我们当时没有录音那部分。你说过，不，不。威尔，实话实说，我并不认为任何一个党派掌握了所有的答案，而且，而且我——我是真的不这么认为。所以当加州州长纽森（Newsom）上节目时，我问了他一些关于他那场命运多舛的晚宴的尖锐问题。你有没有让他承认他需要清理森林并把落叶耙起来？
Somebody needs to hold his feet to the rake on that. Nice. Well, you, so listen on, on that, can I, I don't want to get into a huge sort of political thing here, but we can. But, but, but given media and people know that you are behind Caitlyn Jenner's campaign for governor. People are. We're going to, we're going to get on that in a second.
得有人在这件事上把他按在耙子上摩擦。太棒了。好吧，所以听着——关于那个，我不想在这里陷入巨大的政治争论，但我们可以。但是，但是，但是鉴于媒体和人们都知道你是凯特琳·詹纳（Caitlyn Jenner）竞选州长幕后的推手。人们都在说。我们一会儿就会聊到这个。
Um, or is it Mary Cary? Do you, do you foresee, do you force, do you don't share a hanger, right? You're in, you're in the next hanger over. Is that true from Caitlyn? Where do you park your, your, your cars and your jets? My jet? Yeah. Yeah.
呃，还是玛丽·凯里（Mary Carey）？你预见，你预见——你们不共用一个机库吧？你在离凯特琳下一个机库远一点的地方吗？是真的吗，从凯特琳那边算起？你把你的车和喷气式飞机停在哪里？我的喷气式飞机？对。是的。在山谷和玛丽·凯里在一起。是的。我喜欢把我的车一直停在我的飞机附近。首先，这是很好的商业逻辑。杰克，你有没有预见到这样一天：媒体，或者我应该说新闻，有义务建立一种审查制度、一个门槛，媒体公司在报道某些事情之前必须达到或通过这个门槛？换句话说，我们有，但这是一种不受监管的标准。
In the valley with Mary Cary. Yeah. I like to keep my cars near my jet always. That's first of all, that's, that's just good business. Jake, do you ever see a time when, uh, when media or I should say news is obligated to have a sort of a vetting system, a, uh, a threshold beyond which, uh, these media companies may or have to go before they report something. In other words, we do, but it's an unregulated standard.
不是吗？比方说《纽约时报》、《华盛顿邮报》，他们必须有两三个消息来源，编辑才会说“行，你可以播这条新闻”，但这在某种程度上是自我监管的。你认为未来会不会有一个全国性或国际性的机构，比如一个客观的机构，让你知道它不是假新闻？不。绝不会有一个客观机构，因为，A，第一修正案排除了这种可能性。
Isn't it? Let's say New York times, Washington Post, they have to have like two or three sources before the editor will say, yes, you can go with that story, but it's sort of self-regulated. Do you think there'll ever be a national or international, like an objective body where you know it's not fake news? No. There will never be an objective body because, uh, A, the First Amendment precludes that sort of thing.
人们可以发表他们想要的任何东西。对。但你必须把它标为观点，而不是像他们那样试图把它包装成事实。嗯，不，因为那样的话，你在每一边都会遭到游说，争论谁能进入那个委员会，谁来决定这件事。到头来，那个委员会本身也会被政治玷污。那是根本无法监管的。答案是，不，我没看到这种情况发生，但我理解你的出发点，因为
People can publish whatever they want. Right. But you have to label it as opinion as opposed to how they try to frame it as fact. Well, no, because then you would have lobbying on every, on every side to like who gets to sit on that committee and who gets to decide that. And then ultimately that very committee will become sullied by politics. Like that would be impossible to regulate. The answer is, no, I don't see that happening, but I understand what you're driving at because
我对此思考了很多，特别是在选举谎言被重复，并且在福克斯以及其他一些网络（根据你的说法，如Newsmax之类）上被所谓“报道”了无数次之后——那就是：根本没有任何标准。没有任何要求。没有任何你必须通过认证的专业组织。所以，当一家新闻机构播出一个完全虚假的故事时，比如乔·拜登想限制你一个月只能吃一个汉堡——对，
I've thought about this a lot, especially after the election lie, um, was repeated and, and quote unquote reported so often on, according to you, on Fox and some of the other networks, uh, Newsmax or whatever, which is there are no standards. There is no requirement. There's no professional organization you have to get certified by. So when you have a news organization that runs with a, a, you know, totally bogus story, like Joe Biden wants to regulate you to one hamburger a month. Right.
我的周末算是泡汤了，但这确实引出了一个问题：牛肉在哪里？我认为这是人们——你总是抛出一些清晰的子弹。你总是喜欢抛出子弹。其中一名国会山骚乱的暴徒甚至在声称，呃，他们甚至在声称“福克斯综合症”，我想，我认为这正是他们的辩护律师对它的称呼，
Um, there goes my weekend, but it does beg the question, where's the beef? And I think that that's something that people are, you are always dropping some clear peller. You always love to drop the peller. One of the insurrectionists is literally claiming, um, that they're claiming literally Foxitis, I think, I think it's literally what, what, what their, what their defense attorney called it. Um, whereby they're trying to find, um, um, an excuse because they were pumped so much information that it caused them to do that.
他们试图借此找借口，因为他们被灌输了太多的信息，导致他们做出了那种事。
They believe that it was true. So when they can establish that reporting stuff that is not true will yield damaging results, you would think that shortly after that, some sort of regulation would follow because somebody might get killed because of the things that people are saying. And it's happened. They have gotten killed. Right. Yeah.
他们相信那是真的。所以当他们能够证实报道不实的事情会产生破坏性的结果时，你就会觉得在那之后不久，某种监管就会随之而来，因为人们说的话可能会导致某人丧命。而且这种事已经发生了。确实有人丧命了。没错。是的。
Uh, so, um, so what do you do about it? Yeah. Right. That's the question. So I did something I've been thinking about a lot and grappling with a lot. And you know, it's funny, the, um, after, uh, the broadcaster in England, um, said something nasty about Meghan Markle about how he didn't think that he didn't believe her. Sure.
呃，所以，嗯，所以你对此有什么看法？是的。没错。这就是问题所在。所以我做了一件我一直在思考并花了很多精力去应对的事。你知道，挺有意思的，那个，呃，在英国的那个主持人，呃，对梅根·马克尔说了些难听的话，说他不觉得他——他不相信她。当然。
Um, they have like a, an independent regulatory body that takes comment, I mean, the parliament runs it or points people and all that, but they have something like that. And Twitter had to put that in with Trump's tweets. Yeah. Yeah. They had to like label things as, okay, this is not true. You can still say it, but we get to put a label on it. That's just sort of like the, the half measure that I would think is possible where you can
呃，他们有一个独立的监管机构来收集评论，我是说，议会运营它或任命人员之类的，但他们有类似的东西。推特对特朗普的推文就不得不加上这个。对。是的。他们不得不给内容贴上标签，比如，好吧，这不是真的。你还是可以发表，但我们要给它贴上标签。这有点像我认为可行的折中方案，你可以
vet something, uh, I've recognized a lot of news is live or a lot of opinion shows are, are somewhat live or, or it doesn't allow for as much time to vet something. Right now it's based on shame, right? Yeah. Yeah. And that obviously doesn't work if you're shameless. It doesn't. Right.
审核某事，呃，我认识到很多新闻都是直播的，或者很多评论节目在某种程度上是直播的，或者它们不允许有那么多时间来审核某事。现在它是基于羞耻感，对吧？对。是的。显然，如果你不知羞耻，这就不起作用。不起作用。对。
Like, so for instance, when CNN messes up and we do just like every news organization, we correct it. If needed, we apologize, et cetera. To maintain credibility for God's sakes. Right. Fox doesn't. So what do we do about that? And I don't think that a government regulation is the answer, but I do grapple with it.
比如，当CNN搞砸了，我们就像任何新闻机构一样进行纠正。如果有必要，我们会道歉，等等。为了维持公信力，看在上帝的份上。没错。福克斯不会。那我们该怎么办？我不认为政府监管是解决办法，但我确实在纠缠于这个问题。
I mean, one of the things that I think needs to be done is I think that there are professional media organizations, whether it's the white house correspondence association or, you know, just various other groups that need to, we need to start asserting ourselves within those groups. Like for instance, yeah, there's a, there's a thing that this is inside baseball and silly sounding, but there's a rotating pool, which is all the major, you know, Fox, CNN, ABC, NBC, CBS, PBS. We all rotate cameras if there's like an event that the government will only let us have
我的意思是，我认为需要做的事情之一是，我认为有专业的新闻媒体机构，无论是白宫记者协会，还是，你知道，各种其他需要采取行动的群体，我们需要在这些群体内部开始确立我们的地位。比如，是的，有一件听起来很内行且很傻的事情，但有一个轮流采访团，包括所有主要的，你知道的，福克斯、CNN、ABC、NBC、CBS、PBS。如果有政府只允许我们拥有的活动，我们都会轮流提供摄像机
one camera. Right. And we all rotate. Right. Well, if one of those organizations, Fox, A, feels no compunction about lying or sharing falsehoods, B, I don't know if you saw, but Governor DeSantis not long ago signed a bill and it was an exclusive on Fox and Friends, which is crazy. That's like the definition of state TV.
一个摄像机。没错。而且我们都轮流。没错。好吧，如果其中一个机构，福克斯，A，对说谎或分享虚假信息毫无负罪感，B，我不知道你有没有看到，但德桑蒂斯州长不久前签署了一项法案，这是《Fox and Friends》的独家采访，这太疯狂了。这简直就是国家电视台的定义。
If one of these organizations is not behaving the way that the others are, I think it's an open question as to whether it should be treated the way all the others are. Right. Of course. Well, and the defenses also on their part is that no, it's the five year old defense, no, you're lying. Right. So it just perpetuates for eternity.
如果这些机构之一的表现与其他机构不同，我认为这是一个悬而未决的问题，即它是否应该受到与其他所有机构相同的对待。对。当然。嗯，他们那边的辩护也是，不，这是五岁小孩的辩护，不，你在撒谎。对。所以它只是永远地延续下去。
That's what causes all of this is like, no, we're telling you, no, you're lying. No, you're lying. We're saying that eventually that perhaps somebody should be the adult and come in and like the FCC just say, okay, you don't have access to the pipe then. And if you want to get your stuff out, you have to, you have to come up just like, just like Twitter did. Listen, we're just going to shut you off from this. You can still get your statements out, you know, if you want to like issue a press release.
这就是导致这一切的原因，就像是，不，我们在告诉你，不，你在撒谎。不，你在撒谎。我们说的是，最终也许应该有人扮演成年人介入，就像联邦通信委员会（FCC）那样直接说，好吧，那你就没有权限使用这个渠道了。如果你想把你的东西发布出去，你必须，你必须提出申请，就像，就像推特做的那样。听着，我们只是要切断你与这个的联系。你仍然可以发表你的声明，你知道，如果你想发布新闻稿的话。
Jason, if that body had existed during the Trump years, what would have happened? Which body? This independent agency, the Bateman Commission. Right. The Bateman Commission. Yeah. If the Bateman Commission. It's a great name.
杰森，如果那个机构在特朗普执政期间存在，会发生什么？哪个机构？这个独立机构，贝特曼委员会。没错。贝特曼委员会。是的。如果贝特曼委员会。这名字真棒。
And it's linked with Corey Lewandowski and Seb Gorka. Right. Well, we wouldn't let those fellas in. We know we would, we would vet, we would have a big, huge community of folks to vote on it that's equally divided between left and right. But the problem is, you're talking about perspective. And even though two people can look at the same thing, they're always going to claim that they look at it a different way.
它和科里·莱万多夫斯基以及塞布·戈尔卡有关。好吧，我们不会让那些家伙进来的。我们知道，我们会审核，我们会有一个由左翼和右翼平均分配的庞大社区来投票决定。但问题是，你在谈论观点。即使两个人看同一件事，他们也总是会声称他们是以不同的方式看待的。
Whatever it is you say, it's going to be tough to move people on that because they're so indoctrinated with these other ideas and that might take longer than just, hey, you know, change your opinion right now. This is going to be a thing that's going to take a while to do because this is something that has been perpetuated. This other perspective has been perpetuated for so long now. I think the Bateman Commission is, is dangerous. Yeah.
无论你说什么，要让人改变看法都会很难，因为他们已经被其他这些想法彻底洗脑了，这可能比单纯的“嘿，你知道，马上改变你的意见”需要更长的时间。这将是一件需要一段时间才能完成的事情，因为这是某种一直在延续的东西。另一个观点已经延续了这么久了。我认为贝特曼委员会是危险的。是的。
That's what I think. By the way, you mentioned the thing about that, that reporter who was held to account in the UK. My favorite part was when that other co-host, the guy who BBC or whatever it was in that morning show, accused him of being diabolical as he stormed off and I thought that was the greatest assessment, he was like, your behavior is diabolical. Not a word you had in your pocket. No, but I've been using it a lot.
我就是这么想的。顺便说一句，你提到了英国那个被追究责任的记者的事情。我最喜欢的部分是另一个联合主持人，那个在早间节目中来自BBC还是什么的家伙，在他气冲冲地离开时指责他恶毒，我认为那是最好的评价，他说，你的行为太恶毒了。这不是你平时会用的词。不，但我现在经常用。
Diabolique. Am I allowed, by the way, to say, by the way, am I allowed to fangirl for a second and say that I'm a big fan of all your work, all three of you? This part will stay in. This part will stay in. This part will stay in. Guys, let him say that. I just want to say to Will, the Lego show that you did was brought us lots of joy.
恶毒。顺便问一下，我能允许自己花一秒钟变成小迷妹，说我是你们三个人所有作品的超级粉丝吗？这部分会保留。这部分会保留。这部分会保留。伙计们，让他说吧。我只想对威尔说，你做的那个乐高节目给我们带来了很多欢乐。
Oh, thanks man. Because I got a big Lego fan or like Lego. My son is really into Legos. Really? So do you get to, do you, will you build sets with him? I used to, he's kind of aged out of it, which is by the tail end of it, we, it was just in time to enjoy Will's show. There's some really cool, challenging adult Lego sets, some of the architectural stuff.
哦，谢谢老兄。因为我是个乐高大粉丝，或者说喜欢乐高。我儿子真的很迷乐高。真的吗？那你有没有，你会不会和他一起搭积木？我以前会，他现在有点过了那个年纪了，不过在最后阶段，我们，正好赶上欣赏威尔的节目。有一些非常酷、很有挑战性的成人乐高套装，比如一些建筑类的东西。
It's very, it's very zen, right? It is very zen. And we have, what's amazing is we have so many, we just finished the, we got the second season coming up is how many incredible builders are coming out of the woodwork and making, and coming on the show. And we can't believe the stuff that they do. And they all say the same similar thing, which is not only they just enjoy it, but they also get, they find it very therapeutic.
这非常，非常禅意，对吧？确实非常禅意。我们有，厉害的是我们有那么多，我们刚刚完成了，第二季就要推出了，有多少出色的乐高拼砌师涌现出来，制作，并来到节目中。我们简直不敢相信他们做出来的东西。他们都说类似的话，不仅是他们很享受，而且他们还发现，他们觉得这非常具有治疗效果。
We did a thing with, with some veterans where we were finding during the pandemic, a lot of veterans were using Lego to help them deal with certain aspects of PTSD, et cetera. And we provided a bunch of Lego sets. And that was really- You're the real hero, Will. I guess, I mean, I'm not, look, that word is thrown around a lot, but I'll, I'll take a lot of care. All his stories kind of end the same way.
我们和一些老兵做过一次活动，我们发现在大流行期间，很多老兵都在利用乐高来帮助他们应对创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的某些方面等等。我们提供了一大堆乐高套装。那真的是——你才是真正的英雄，威尔。我想，我是说，我不是，听着，那个词被滥用了，但我会，我会非常小心。他所有的故事结局都差不多。
Yeah. Well, they said that we don't need another hero, but I, I disagree. Nice. Jake, how are you, can, can you give us a, a sort of a, a breakdown of, of your day and how you delegate your, your, your time, a typical day for you. What time do you get up? How much time do you spend researching the newspapers? 10 a.m. out of bed.
是的。嗯，他们说我们不需要另一个英雄，但我，我不同意。太棒了。杰克，你好吗，能，你能给我们，大致介绍一下，你的日常生活，你是如何委派你的，你的，时间的，你典型的一天是怎样的？你几点起床？你花多少时间研究报纸？上午10点起床。
10 a.m. That's late. Seven, you know, seven up. What happens right at seven? Do we go right for the coffee or do we go right for the paper? Right for my phone to read the newspaper. Now are you in bed? Does that phone sleep next to you or are you disciplined about, or do you have to keep
上午10点。太晚了。7点，你知道，7点起床。7点整会发生什么？我们是直接去喝咖啡还是直接去看报纸？直接拿手机看报纸。那你还在床上吗？那个手机是挨着你睡的，还是你很有纪律，或者你必须
it on in case something happens while you're sleeping? I have to keep it on in case somebody needs to call me to wake me up in the middle of the night for whatever reason. I, and I did that one time, by the way, one time I'd been only been on air at CNN for about a month and I was in Boston covering the Boston Marathon bombing and they had not caught the Sarnayev brothers yet. And then it was like 1130 or 12 at night and I was just sitting in the hotel room online and then people start tweeting at me the web address of the Somerville, Massachusetts police
开着它以防你睡觉时发生什么事？我必须开着它，以防有人需要因为某种原因在半夜打电话叫醒我。而且我以前就这么做过一次，顺便说一句，就一次，我在CNN刚播音大约一个月，我当时在波士顿报道波士顿马拉松爆炸案，他们还没有抓到萨尔纳耶夫兄弟。然后大概是晚上11点半或12点，我正坐在酒店房间里上网，接着人们开始在推特上@我萨默维尔，马萨诸塞州警察局的网址
radio scanner for the, and anyway, long story short, I spent the whole night up on air and there were people, I still hear from them every now and then who went through this experience with me where we're like, we were getting these reports and obviously this was the confrontation where one of the other, one of the brothers got killed and then the other brother escaped and then hid in the boat and all that. And we were all getting all this weird news in the middle of the night. Anyway, so just in case that were out to ever happen. But so you have to sleep, getting back to this because it's like right out of a movie,
无线电扫描仪的，不管怎样，长话短说，我整晚都在直播，有人——我到现在还时不时能听到他们的消息——他们和我一起经历了这段经历，当时我们就像是，我们收到了这些报道，显然这是一场对峙，其中一个兄弟被杀，然后另一个兄弟逃跑了，然后藏在船里之类的。我们半夜都在接收所有这些奇怪的新闻。不管怎样，以防万一这种事再次发生。但是你得睡觉，回到这个话题上来，因为这就像电影里的情节一样，
right? Right here. But you're not, it's not, it's not buzzing or beeping every time email or text. So you have a specific number that is, that's the only one that will bleed through and wake you up. And that is, would be a hotline from your, no, it's my phone's on. I mean, if somebody wants to call me, it's just your phone is on. They could wake me up.
就在这里。但你，它不是，它不是每次有电子邮件或短信时都在震动或蜂鸣。所以你有一个特定的号码，那是唯一一个能够穿透并叫醒你的号码。那会是来自你的热线吗？不，我的手机是开着的。我是说，如果有人想给我打电话，只是你的手机开着。他们可以叫醒我。
Anybody could. You could, Jason, you have my number. How often do you, do you erroneously have your, your flashlight on and you have to be told, Hey, granddad, turn off your flashlight. Oh, Jake. Jake, does that happen a lot? We're all getting old, right? It's okay.
任何人都可以。你可以，杰森，你有我的号码。你多久会，会错误地打开手电筒，然后不得不被人提醒，嘿，老头子，把手电筒关掉？哦，杰克。杰克，这种事经常发生吗？我们都在变老，对吧？没关系。
Jake, admit it. Am I the oldest one on this call? I'm 52. I might be. I look the youngest. Are you older than, than 52? Cause I think I'm the oldest of the three of us, right? I'm 52.
杰克，承认吧。我是这个通话里年龄最大的人吗？我52岁了。我可能是。我看起来最年轻。你比，比52岁大吗？因为我觉得我是我们三个里面年龄最大的，对吧？我52岁。
You're 52. When's your birthday? March. Okay. Then I'm in January. So I'm the, I'm the oldest. You're the oldest. Interesting.
你52岁。你什么时候生日？三月。好吧。那我是一月。所以我，我是老大。你是老大。有趣。
Interesting. This is the oldest. Do you want to know my day? My day is this. Yes. I get up early. I read, I read, I read. The kids leave the house at eight.
有趣。这是老大。你想知道我的一天吗？我的一天是这样的。是的。我起得很早。我阅读，我阅读，我阅读。孩子们8点离开家。
My talk to my executive producer at eight 30. And then from eight 30 until one, one, 30, I'm doing a combination of one, one, 30. A combination of interviewing, talking to sources, reading, exercising, and getting to work. Now, are you doing work on your exercise and when you're exercising, I'm imagining cardio on a, on a treadmill and there's some sort of either computer or, or in front of you or a phone. Wait, wait, wait.
8点半和我的执行制片人通话。然后从8点半到1点，1点半，我在做结合了1点，1点半的事情。结合了采访、与消息源交谈、阅读、锻炼和开始工作。那么，你在锻炼的时候也在工作吗？当你在锻炼时，我猜是在跑步机上做有氧运动，然后你面前或者有某种电脑，或者，或者手机。等等，等等，等等。
Don't, don't, don't answer yet. Don't answer yet. Sean, you also guess, guess the exercise and then I'm going to guess too. Okay. So I've got them on a treadmill. You said treadmill. Sean, what do you think Jake does? High pace walking, high hands walking.
别，别，别回答。别回答。肖恩，你也猜，猜一下是什么锻炼，然后我也要猜。好吧。所以我猜他们在跑步机上。你说了跑步机。肖恩，你觉得杰克在做什么？快步走，高抬手走路。
Sean, what do you think? It's a Peloton thing. I don't know. It's a Peloton. Okay. I think, I think elliptical. Okay. So he's got both hands moving forward.
肖恩，你觉得呢？这是一个Peloton单车。我不知道。是个Peloton。好吧。我觉得，我觉得是椭圆机。好吧。所以他双手都在向前移动。
Well, or he could do also just the steady hand. He doesn't. No, I, I want to change my answer. I think he just sits on a yoga ball and he calls that and he bounces slowly. He calls that exercise. He calls that exercise. Okay. He calls that exercise.
好吧，或者他也可以只是双手保持稳定。他不。不，我要改变我的答案。我觉得他只是坐在瑜伽球上，他把那叫做运动，然后慢慢地弹。他把那叫做运动。他把那叫做运动。好吧。他把那叫做运动。
Jake. First of all, the implication is none of you think I look that good. No, you look incredible. I said elliptical. You look incredible. I mean, elliptical stuff. You look elliptical thin. Yeah.
杰克。首先，这意味着你们觉得我看起来没那么好。不，你看起来棒极了。我说的是椭圆机。你看起来棒极了。我是说，椭圆机的那种。你看起来像椭圆机那样苗条。是的。
Wait, wait, wait, wait. Shit. The thing is rowing machine. Probably. I think he's a row machine guy. How dare you? I'm switching. I'm switching before you.
等等，等等，等等，等等。靠。重点是划船机。很可能。我觉得他是划船机那种人。你怎么敢？我要换了。我在你之前换。
The ERG machine, the people, the crew guys in college always look so good. That's what I thought because I thought Pennsylvania, you might be like a crew guy. Okay. Go ahead. So before the pandemic, it was like a, I had a trainer that went to a gym. It was like a lot of stuff. You did look great before the pandemic. So pandemic era, which is what we're in.
那个ERG划船机，大学里的那些划船手总是看起来那么好。我就是这么想的，因为我想宾夕法尼亚州，你可能是那种划船手。好吧。请继续。所以在大流行之前，就像是，我有一个去健身房的教练。就像有很多项目。你在大流行之前看起来确实很棒。所以是大流行时期，也就是我们现在所处的时期。
I will just answer that, which is you should have kept with Peloton, Sean, because it was Peloton. Okay. And I watched a movie. Watch a movie. I'm making my way through the Marvel Cinematic Universe now. Headphones or speakers? It's just speakers.
我直接回答吧，那就是你应该坚持用Peloton的，肖恩，因为确实是Peloton。好吧。我一边看电影。看电影。我现在正在把漫威电影宇宙的电影都看一遍。戴着耳机还是用外放？就是外放。
The nobody's, nobody's in, I have a little gym room. Yeah. Cause headphones get sweaty. What are you shaking your head? Jason's disappointed in me for watching superhero movies. No, I'm thinking about the will in his sweaty headphones. I just, I just, I can tell there's probably just sets and sets of them. I watched Teen Wolf two.
没，没有人，我有一个小健身房。对。因为戴耳机容易出汗。你在摇什么头？杰森对我看超级英雄电影感到失望。不，我在想威尔和他的汗湿耳机。我只是，我只是能看出那可能就是一套又一套的。我看了《狼人少年2》。
Oh. You had to get pumped. That'll make you sweat. With the long hair. You're writing a book. You're doing the thing. And you're going to the, like, is your family like, Hey, remember us? Good question.
哦。你得给自己打打气。那会让你出汗。留着长头发。你在写书。你在忙这些事情。然后你去，就像，你的家人会不会说，嘿，还记得我们吗？好问题。
Like, do they ever go like, Hey, can you're working way too much? Cause to me, you just, you work so much. But the kids are at school. Where's mom? Kids are at school at this point. Mom is working. She does some freelance consulting and stuff. I mean, I spent time with the kids in the morning and quick, what are their names?
就像，他们会不会说，嘿，你工作是不是太多了？因为在我看来，你，你工作实在太多了。但孩子们在学校。妈妈在哪儿？这个时候孩子们在学校。妈妈在工作。她做一些自由职业咨询之类的事情。我是说，我早上会陪陪孩子们，快告诉我，他们叫什么名字？
Hey, listen, why'd your voice go up? We're not accusing you of anything, Jeff. So defensive. Alice is 13 and Jack is 11. Can you remember their middle names? Paul and Jack Raymond. Good for you. That's nice.
嘿，听着，你的声音怎么提高八度了？我们又没有指责你什么，杰夫。防备心这么强。爱丽丝13岁，杰克11岁。你还记得他们的中间名吗？保罗和杰克·雷蒙德。真不错。太棒了。
Really, really tight. Will quick. What are your kids' names? Starting with direction. And Sean. Yeah. I sold mine. Okay.
真的，真的很亲密。威尔，快说。你的孩子叫什么名字？从方向开始。还有肖恩。对。我把他们卖了。好吧。
Uh, tell me work where, where, uh, illustration, cartoon drawing and all that stuff still lives or not in your, in your world. Oh, you know, so I wanted to be a cartoonist. That's what I wanted to do. And I spent years and years trying to be the next Gary Trudeau or the next Jimmy Kimmel. You know, he's got a pretty good pen on him. I know. He's, he's an excellent artist.
呃，告诉我，插画、卡通画和所有这些东西在你的世界里是否还存在，还是已经不在了？哦，你知道的，所以我想成为一名漫画家。那是我一直想做的事。我花了好几年时间试图成为下一个加里·特鲁多（Gary Trudeau）或下一个吉米·金梅尔（Jimmy Kimmel）。你知道，他很有两下子。我知道。他是一位出色的艺术家。
There's a better way to say that. He has a cartoon that I drew of him and I have a cartoon that he drew of me in our homes. Nice. Cue the love music. I love Jimmy. Jake, were you the one who provided the video recently of Jason on his first appearance on The Tonight Show? On The Tonight Show.
有更好的说法。我们家里挂着一张我画他的漫画，他也挂着一张他画我的漫画。太棒了。播放爱情音乐。我爱吉米。杰克，你是不是最近提供了杰森在《今夜秀》首次亮相时的视频的那个人？在《今夜秀》上。
Yes. That's right. It really, it made it its way into an extended chain, a text chain that we have and Jason took heat for like an hour and a half. Of Joseph Bateman? Joseph Bateman's first appearance on The Tonight Show. Do you see, do you see how, a moment of self-indulgence, do you see how obnoxiously calm and confident that douchebag I was at 15?
是的。没错。它确实被发到了我们有一个群聊的长消息链里，杰森被吐槽了一个半小时。约瑟夫·贝特曼的？约瑟夫·贝特曼在《今夜秀》上的首次亮相。你们看，你们看，自我陶醉的一刻，你们看到我15岁时那个混蛋是多么厚颜无耻地冷静和自信吗？
Like why, why was I so comfy there in front of Johnny Carson? I mean, there's such a- Well, we know, we know why. Everybody, everybody thinks- Because you were two weeks removed from what? Oh yeah. What's that? Well, I became sexually active at 15.
就像为什么，为什么我在约翰尼·卡森面前那么自在？我的意思是，有这样一种——嗯，我们知道，我们知道为什么。每个人，每个人都觉得——因为你离那时候只有两周？哦，对。什么？嗯，我15岁时就有了性生活。
You had just lost this. To put it, yeah. Yeah. You had just like two weeks before lost your virginity before you went to Carson? Yeah. I believe that about times out. No wonder you were smoking a cigarette. Yeah.
你刚刚失去这个。这么说吧，对。是的。你在去卡森那里之前大概两周刚刚失去了童贞？对。我觉得时间差不多。难怪你在抽烟。对。
I was beat, yeah. But no, were you guys, do you guys remember being as fond of yourself at 15 as I was? I mean, there's- Well, none of us remember being on Johnny Carson when we were 15. No, but there's a blissful ignorance at that age, right? But that was your whole thing at that time. It's your move, right? That was what you were selling on The Tonight Show.
我累了，对。但是不，你们，你们还记得自己在15岁时像我一样自我感觉良好吗？我的意思是——嗯，我们都不记得自己在15岁时上过约翰尼·卡森的节目。不，但那个年纪有一种无知的美好，对吧？但那正是你当时所有的全部。这是你的招牌，对吧？那正是你在《今夜秀》上兜售的东西。
Thankfully, I thought it was never going to descend. God, we loved- I loved that show. Did you guys love that show as much as I did? It was a great show. Yeah. It was so good. I don't think it holds up.
谢天谢地，我当时以为它永远不会走下坡路。天哪，我们太爱了——我太爱那个节目了。你们像我一样那么爱那个节目吗？那是个很棒的节目。是的。太棒了。我觉得它现在经不起推敲。
Shawn, did you love it? You loved that it's your move, right? I loved everything Jason Bateman has ever done. It's your move was really good, but I don't recall it lasting that long. Am I wrong about that? No. It was less than a season. Yeah.
肖恩，你喜欢它吗？你喜欢那是你的招牌，对吧？我喜欢杰森·贝特曼做过的一切。《这是你的招牌》真的很棒，但我不记得它播了那么久。我记错了吗？没有。不到一季。是的。
You know what, guys? I love it when I can shape an interview into something about me. I end up doing this quite a bit. It's a talent. I really started it because I'm the one that, and it's my fault because I sent that Johnny Carson clip to you. And it's just like wildfire. Yeah.
你知道吗，伙计们？我最喜欢的就是能把采访引导到关于我自己的话题上。我最后经常这么干。这是一种天赋。我其实是挑头的那个人，这都怪我，因为我把那个约翰尼·卡森的剪辑发给了你们。然后就像野火一样传开了。是的。
You did seem like a douche on Carson though. That's true. Right. Well, you know why? Because I pointed out on our chain the other day that he was, he was a douche because he was knee-deep in Valley Beve at that point. So he just had that confidence in Valley Beve. And also what was so amazing about it was, well, first of all, I thought Carson was kind
你在卡森节目上看起来确实像个混蛋。那是真的。好吧，你知道为什么吗？因为我前几天在我们的群里指出，他，他是个混蛋，因为他当时正深陷山谷女孩（Valley Beve）的文化中，所以他才有了那种山谷女孩般的自信。而且同样令人惊奇的是，嗯，首先，我觉得卡森有点，我觉得那些问题有点难。他问你是否相信前世。是的。
of, I thought the questions were kind of tough. He's asking you about whether or not you believe in past lives. Yeah. You're 15. You're 15. What the hell? Those were some real crazy questions. And then-
你15岁。你15岁。搞什么鬼？那些都是些真正疯狂的问题。然后——你会，你会在你的节目中问别人是否相信那种事吗？这个问题是基于这样一个事实，即他把杰森的名字搞砸了。他叫他乔。是的，我知道。然后他试图为自己解围。
Would you ask, would you never ask somebody on your show if they believed in that? The question was based on the fact that he had fucked up Jason's name. He'd called him Joe. Yeah, I know. And then he'd try to crawl out of it. By the way, I revere Carson and everything, but to try to crawl out of it, all of a sudden he's acting as if perhaps he was actually Joseph Bateman and like, do you believe in other lives?
顺便说一句，我对卡森顶礼膜拜，但为了解围，他突然表现得好像他实际上就是约瑟夫·贝特曼一样，还问诸如“你相信有来世吗？你相信前世吗？”之类的话。他只是把名字搞砸了，老兄。你不得不佩服那种脱身的方式，试图用那种方式摆脱尴尬。我的意思是，那是一种相当深奥的脱身方法。我们甚至都没有说他在介绍你的时候说错了名字？我不知道他有没有说过。
Do you believe in past lives? He's just fucked up the name, man. You got to admire the bailout, the attempt to get out of it with that. I mean, that's a pretty deep way to get out of it. Did we even say that when he introduced you, he said the wrong name? I don't know if he ever said that. Yes, yeah. He did.
是的，是的。他说了。把我介绍为约瑟夫·贝特曼。然后我——哦，没有人在这个上面说。是的，因为我们的电话线都被威斯康星州的人打爆了。你认为这个弥天大谎有可持续性，并且会一直延续到下次选举吗？因为我认为下一次总统辩论中主持人最具杀伤力的问题将是直接针对共和党候选人，问他们：你相信这件事发生了吗？
Introduce me as Joseph Bateman. And then I- Oh, nobody said it on this. Yeah, because our phone lines were lighting up from Wisconsin. Do you think that this big lie has sustainability and will go all the way to the next election? Because I think the hardest-hitting question for a moderator in the next presidential debate is going to be directly at the Republican candidate and saying, do you believe that this happened?
但我们对此已经知道答案了，因为这个问题已经被问过并回答过了。我猜你会遇到这样的人：要么是彻头彻尾的选举阴谋论者，声称选举被偷了；要么是那种试图走中间路线、说诸如“我对选举有很多疑问，很多州通过了紧急立法，我认为这违反了他们州的宪法。我对选举有很多担忧，这就是为什么我们在我的州通过了这样那样的法律。但我希望向前看，等等等等”的人，这基本上就是不谴责
But we'll know the answer to that already because that question will have been asked and answered. And what I suspect is you will either have somebody who is a full-blown election truther and says the election was stolen, or you will have somebody who tries to walk the line and say things like, I have a lot of questions about the election, a lot of states passed emergency legislation that I thought was in violation of their state's constitutions. I have a lot of concerns about it, which is why we passed such and such in my state. But I want to look forward, blah, blah, blah, blah, which is basically not denouncing the
选举谎言，也没有完全接受它，试图走一条中间路线。我猜下一个共和党提名人会这么做，并且把记者们狠狠教训一通，让他们不再试图得到一个明确的答案。这行不通。我的意思是，你可以追随特朗普，并认为外面有足够多的选民让它起作用。但现在已经两次证明了，这根本不够多的人。他们得推出一个不同的候选人，对吧，或者有不同的……
election lie, not fully embracing it, trying to walk a line. And I suspect the next Republican nominee will do that and beat up reporters enough so that they stop trying to get a definitive answer. It didn't work. I mean, you can follow Trump and assume that there's enough voters out there for it to work. But it's been proven now twice that it's just simply not enough people. They got to put a different candidate up, right, or have a different...
我不知道。神学。我不知道。我的意思是，作为一个总体的看法，我同意你所说的，共和党未来的发展需要更加包容。他们不能把像利兹·切尼和米特·罗姆尼这样的人逐出党外。他们需要拥抱事实和真理，并分享他们的观点和看法。但我不知道他们是否会这样做。
I don't know. Theology. I don't know. I mean, as a general note, I agree with what you're saying that the future of the Republican party needs to be more expansive. They can't be kicking people like Liz Cheney and Mitt Romney out of the party. They need to embrace facts and truth and share their opinions and their views. But I don't know that they're going to do that.
而且我也不知道这是否是他们赢得总统大选的唯一途径。我不知道。我的意思是，我们走着瞧。我的意思是，这是可能的……我的意思是，民主党选民并不一定是极度可靠的。我的意思是，在你们居住的加利福尼亚州是的，但在关键摇摆州，他们不是。顺便说一句，我们是好莱坞精英，我们是自由派精英。你不喜欢我说仅仅是加利福尼亚。
And I don't know that that's the only way that they can win a presidential election. I don't know that. I mean, we'll see. I mean, it's possible that... I mean, Democratic voters are not necessarily hugely reliable. I mean, they are where you guys live in California, but in battleground states, they're not. We're a Hollywood elite, by the way, we're liberal elites. You don't like it when I just say California.
你想确保我具体指出马里布、威尼斯海滩。顺便说一句，我来自多伦多，肖恩来自芝加哥，杰森来自山谷（The Valley），那至少要开车40分钟。在交通高峰期，算了吧，我才不来呢。你是多伦多市的人吗？我来自多伦多市中心。我是在那里长大的，是的。
You want to make sure that I'm identifying Malibu, Venice Beach. By the way, I'm from Toronto, Sean's from Chicago, and Jason's from the Valley, which is at least a 40-minute drive. In rush hour, forget it, and I'm not coming. You're from the city of Toronto? I'm from downtown Toronto. I grew up, yeah. Yeah?
是吗？是的，那是个好地方。我在你的声音里感到了那种粗犷、坚韧的根基。是的，是的。多伦多市中心（TL, T-Zero）那条硬核的街道。我在电视上和推特上对总理特鲁多发表了批评性的言论，然后……你必须得是加拿大人。天哪，那些加拿大人有时真是不礼貌。我学到了。
Yeah, it's a good town. I feel the rough, scrabble roots in your voice. Yeah, yeah. The hard-nosed streets of TL, T-Zero. I said something critical of Prime Minister Trudeau on TV and on Twitter, and... You got to be Canadian. Boy, those Canadians can be impolite. I learned.
他们非常不礼貌。另外，我要说的是，作为一个近30年前搬到这里来的加拿大人，30多年前，当我刚来这里的时候，我心里有一种强烈的不平衡感，因为你觉得自己是美国的跟班小弟弟，所以你会有那种心理，而且我在很长一段时间里都对加拿大充满防备心，我会说，嗯，我们做了这个，我们做了那个。我们讨论了很多。我们有威廉·夏 Shatner。是的，我们有他。
They're very impolite. And also, I will say this, as a Canadian who moved down here almost 30 years ago, more than 30 years ago, when I came here, I had such a chip on my shoulder because you feel like you're the kid brother of the U.S., and so you have that thing, and I was so defensive about Canada for so long, and I'd be like, well, we do this, and we do that. We've talked a lot about it. We have William Shatner. Yeah, we have him.
我知道。我们不断地指认每一个著名的加拿大人，比如有人会说，嘿，其实我看过这部迈克·梅尔斯演的精彩电影。他是加拿大人。我们就会说，是的，我们知道，老兄。我们懂。而且……但确实有那种心态，所以我认为他们非常……
I know. We're constantly calling out everybody who's a famous Canadian, like somebody will go, yeah, so I actually saw this great movie with Mike Myers. He's Canadian. We're like, yeah, we know, man. We got it. And... But there is that thing, and so I think that they're very...
他们会非常有防备心，我懂。因为我自己也经历过那种心理。你确实觉得……你现在是美国人了么？我是，两者都是。我是双重国籍。你是双重的。我是双重的，感觉我像是双性恋，而且……
They can be very defensive, and I get it. Because I went through that myself. You do feel... Are you an American now? I am, both. I'm both. You're a dual. I'm dual, and it feels like I'm bi, and...
大家别挂电话。不。不，不，抱歉。我不是说双性恋。不，不，不。我只是说我是个双重公民。但你觉得……如果用冰球做一个类比，我们在很多文化层面上觉得非常相似，
Don't hang up, everybody. No. No, no, sorry. I'm not saying bi. No, no, no. It's just I'm bi, a citizen. But you feel like... And to make a hockey analogy, we feel like we're very similar in a lot of ways culturally,
但我们就像在冰场边缘隔着玻璃向里看，就在中圈附近。我们有极佳的座位。我们有极佳的座位。我喜欢。我喜欢。这是一个不可思议的国家。你们喜欢冰球吗？我们还在谈论多伦多吗？
but we're up against the glass kind of looking in like right at center ice. We got great seats. We got great seats. I like it. I like it. It is an incredible country. Do you guys like hockey? Are we still talking about Toronto?
哦，抱歉。我们是想把话题扯回该死的《狼人少年2》吗？对。真他妈的。我们才聊了11分钟呢。杰克，非常抱歉占用了你的时间。我当时——不管怎样，我唯一的观点是，我惊讶于总理特鲁多的粉丝对他的忠诚
Oh, sorry. Did we want to bring it back to fucking Teen Wolf 2? Yeah. Fuck's sake. We only did 11 minutes of it. Jake, I'm so sorry to have taken your time. I was... Anyway, my only point was I was amazed that Prime Minister Trudeau's fans were as loyal
和崇拜程度，就像特朗普的粉丝或奥巴马的粉丝对他们那样。杰克，这就是我的观点。他们才不是。他们在家里自己的对话中也是那样的人，但因为你是美国人，而你说了这话，所以他们才产生了防御心理。确实如此。任何听到这话并不同意我的加拿大人，你就是在撒谎。杰克，是老鹰队还是费城人队？
and devoted to him as Trump's fans or Obama's fans are to him. Jake, this is my point. They're not. They're like those same people in their own conversations at home, but because you're American and you said it, then they're defensive. And that's true. And any Canadian who's listening to this who disagrees with me, you're lying. Jake, Eagles or Phillies?
为什么我非得选？你必须选。你必须选。把枪顶在脑袋上。枪就顶在你的脑袋上。好吧，你知道吗，肖恩，你先来。肖恩，你先来。老鹰队还是费城人队？
Why do I have to pick? You have to pick. You have to. Guns to your head. The gun is right to your head. Well, you know what, Sean, you go first. Sean, you go first. Eagles or Phillies?
我给你个台阶下。我会说2021年，你更看好哪一个？费城人队。费城人队。好吧。是的，我现在很为老鹰队担心。我觉得所有把我们带到超级碗的人都走了。我也是。
I'll give you an out there. I will say for 2021, which are you more bullish on? Phillies. Phillies. Okay. Yeah, I'm really worried about the Eagles right now. I feel like everybody that took us to the Super Bowl is gone. I am too.
肖恩，你也有同感吗，肖恩？哦，天哪，是的。鲍比·克拉克（Bobby Clarke）还是埃里克·林德罗斯（Eric Lindros）？林德罗斯。真的吗？好吧。因为我认识林德罗斯。当然。
Sean, you share his concerns, Sean? Oh, God, yeah. Bobby Clark or Eric Lindros? Lindros. Really? Okay. Well, because I know Lindros. Of course.
你认识？当然。我去过一场老鹰队的比赛并遇到了他。埃里克·林德罗斯现在在干什么？他在加拿大。他是一个……你知道他在忙什么吗？大概在280到298美元之间吧。
Do you? Of course. I went to an Eagles game and met him. What's Eric Lindros doing nowadays? He's up in Canada. He's a... Do you know what he's up to? Maybe $280 to $298.
他就在搞这个。我不知道。我只是——顺便说一句，开玩笑的，我确信他状态极佳，我可不想让他揍我。杰克，你接下来的日程安排是怎样的？今天是星期六。你今天要干什么？
That's what he's up to. I don't know. I'm just... By the way, just kidding, I'm sure he's in great shape and I don't want him to beat me up. Jake, what does the rest of your day look like? It's Saturday. What are you going to do today?
再写几本书。做完这个采访后，我要去采访白宫新冠病毒应对主任。哦，天哪。替我们问好。全是科学。这将在周日早晨播出。替我们问好。然后我回来，我会为明天的节目做准备，并和我的儿子玩。
Write a couple more books. Right after this, I'm doing an interview with the White House director of COVID. Oh, my God. Say hi for us. Just science. That's going to air on Sunday morning. Say hi for us. Then I come back and I'll prepare for tomorrow's show and play with my son.
你有没有一部分……我是说，我是一个政治迷。我只是——我喜欢在新闻里看政治并阅读相关内容。顺便说一句，你应该读读《恶魔可能会跳舞》（The Devil May Dance），这是……哦，那是什么？那是一本新书吗？里面有很多政治内容。
Is there a part of you... I mean, I'm such a fan of politics. I just... I love watching the politics on the news and reading about it. Then by the way, you should read The Devil May Dance, which is... Oh, what is that? Is that a new book? Has a lot of politics in it.
这是关于在迪斯科舞厅里寻找你的灵魂伴侣。并不是。但我知道这是你向所有听众推荐购买的书。这是一本现在就能买到的书吗？现在就能买到。是的。书店有售。你可以在亚马逊上买到。
This is about finding your soulmate in the disco. It's not. But I know it's a book that you're recommending all of your listeners to purchase. Is it a book that's available now? It's available now. Yes. It's a bookstores. You can get it on Amazon.
你可以在巴诺书店（Barnes & Noble）买到。你可以在 jaketapper.com 上买到。你可以买到。杰克，我要读一读。在我们三个当中，我是唯一一个阅读的人，我要读那本书，而且我不会对你提出任何意见。现在就先说好。我真的很喜欢它。
You can get it at Barnes & Noble. You can get it on jaketapper.com. You can get it. Jake, I'm going to read it. Of the three of us, I'm the only one who reads and I'm going to read that book and I'm not going to have any notes for you. Just know now. I really enjoy it.
你今天在《纽约时报》上得到了极高的评价。我得到了《纽约时报》的高度赞扬。你从来不会得到那个。不会。我要告诉你……我觉得你们其实会喜欢它的。这是关于60年代的好莱坞。让我告诉你为什么你会喜欢它。
You got a rave review in the New York Times today. I got a New York Times rave review. You never get that. No. I'm going to tell you... I think you guys actually would like it. It's about Hollywood in the 60s. Let me tell you why you would like it.
我现在不喜欢好莱坞。我为什么会喜欢那个时候的？听着，《纽约时报》是这样说的。《纽约时报》说，这本惊悚小说的齿轮运转精妙且迅速。这本书的严肃性从未妨碍它带来令人窒息的乐趣。塔珀显然很享受搜集素材、写作的过程，并且运用了——你能从头到尾停止这种博弈吗？正当你以为他从帽子里拉出了最大的兔子时，结果证明他
I don't like Hollywood now. Why would I like it back then? Listen, per the New York Times. The New York Times says, the gears of this thriller move expertly and fast. The seriousness of this book never gets in the way of the breathless fun. Tapper obviously enjoyed sourcing it, writing it and using, can you stop this gamesmanship from start to finish? Just when you think he's pulled the biggest rabbit out of his hat, he turns out to have
藏了更大的东西。他还把玛格丽特塑造成了一个极佳的榜样，许多人都会喜欢这本生机勃勃的书。顺便说一句……真不错，杰克。拜托。《纽约时报》可不会随随便便给出高度评价。他们不会的。
been hiding something even bigger. He also makes Margaret a wonderful role model for many people who will enjoy this buoyant book. By the way... Good for you, Jake. Come on. New York Times doesn't just hand out raves. They don't.
他们不会的。我的书评是：小心在人间跳探戈，因为恶魔可能会跳舞。今天的采访就到这里，塔珀先生。我很乐意给你们每人寄一本。我有复印件。杰森有我的号码。我会很想要那本书的。哦，天哪。
They don't. My review is be careful about wanting to tango in hell because the devil may dance. And that's going to end our interview today, Mr. Tapper. I'm happy to send you all copies. I was copies. Jason has my number. I would love that book. Oh my God.
你要加入一个群聊了。你马上就会想退出的。肖恩经常发送滑板小猫咪的最棒视频。它们会让你的日子充满活力。还有背着狗的小猫。小猫和小狗。小猫和小狗。我很乐意发起一个，你知道的，短信群聊。
You're going to get on a thread. You're going to want to leave immediately. Sean sends the greatest videos of little kitties on skateboards. They'll keep your day moving. Falling off with dogs on them. Kittens and puppies. Kittens and puppies. I'm happy to start like a, you know, a text chain.
没问题。小心你的愿望成真。我是说，如果你想的话。如果你想这么做的话。准备好了吗？塔珀先生。多伦多枫叶队24小时全天候新闻。我太兴奋了。
You got it. Careful what you wish for. I mean, if you want. If you want to do it. Ready? Mr. Tapper. Toronto Maple Leaf News 24-7. I'm so excited.
我很感激你的时间，因为我们已经确定它是非常宝贵且非常满意的。所以谢谢你今天和我们分享这段时光。顺便说一句，我很抱歉时间这么早，但我……我只想抱怨一下。当我的助理告诉我我们要在太平洋时间早上8点做这个时，我说，那不可能是对的，因为我确信你们都在睡觉。好吧，至少威尔的脸还泡在一罐冰里。这就是为什么它那么美丽，而你们呢……
I appreciate your time because we've established it's very valuable and very crowded. So thank you for sharing this bit with us today. By the way, I apologize that it was so early, but I... I'd just like to complain. When my assistant told me we were doing this at 8 a.m. Pacific time, I said, that can't be right because I'm pretty sure they'll all be sleeping. Well, at least Will's face is in a jar of ice still. That's why it's so beautiful and they're, you know...
谢谢你，杰克。我从5点45就开始起床了。我从5点45就开始起床了，因为我在看利兹对托特纳姆热刺的比赛以及来自西班牙的F1排位赛。一样。我也是。好吧，哈。
Thank you, Jake. I've been up since 5.45. I've been up since 5.45 because I was watching Leeds Tottenham and Formula One Qualifying from Spain. Same. And same. Well, huh. Okay.
谢谢你，杰克。杰克。哇。谢谢你，老兄。好的。在群里联系我。那个杰克·塔珀，你知道，他看起来……他真的是一个——再次，我用“成年人”这个词。
Thank you, Jake. Jake. Wow. Thank you, man. All right. Hit me up on the thread. And that Jake Tapper, you know, he seems like such... He is such a, again, I use the word adult.
就像他知道……他太聪明了。他与所有这些世界领袖对话。但当你在这种形式下跟他对话时，他就像个普通人，穿着他那件小连帽衫，头发乱蓬蓬的。他……我刚才说的就是这个意思，杰森，就像……那种老师的典故，对吧？
Like he knows... He's so smart. He talks to all these world leaders. But when you talk to him like in this form, he's just such a regular guy and he's got his little hoodie on and his hair's all messed up. And he's... That's what I was talking about too, Jason, was like to... That teacher reference, right?
当你还是个孩子的时候，你在学校环境之外看到一个老师，就像是，哦，你看，那是穿着连帽衫、像个普通人的杰克·塔珀，这需要花一点时间才能把这笔账合上。对，他……我简直不敢相信他在整个采访中都在抽大麻，因为我觉得那太不可思议了。对于一个跑新闻的人来说。抽了那么多大麻？
When you're a kid and you see a teacher outside of their environment and school, it's like, oh, you see, there's Jake Tapper with a hoodie on and like a regular person, it takes a while to add it up. Yeah, he's... I can't believe he smoked weed the entire interview, too, because I thought that was unbelievable. For a guy who covers the news. Did that much weed?
他真的……他保持着清醒的头脑。是的。而且他一直说，我有这种黏糊糊的BC大麻。我有这种黏糊糊的……但老实说，他会，就像他会——我希望他不会因为我透露这个而生我的气——他会在他的节目进行中间给我发最无聊的短信。就像他能够同时抛接那么多球或者转盘子，或者无论那个短语是什么。
He really... He kept his wits about him. Yeah. And he kept saying, I got this sticky, BC bug. I got this sticky... But you know, in all honesty, he would, like he will, and I hope he doesn't get mad at me for revealing this, he will text me the most inane stuff in the middle of his show. Like he's able to juggle so many balls or spin plates or whatever the phrase is.
他只是……我不知道他是怎么做到两兼顾的。顺便说一句，这也许就是像他这样的人的特点，因为他必须这样做，所以他才不得不给你发短信。就像他必须让所有事情一直运转下去，因为如果他不这样做，那么底线就会崩溃，然后他就会蜷缩在角落里抱头痛哭。而这正是我想要看到的。而且我希望——
He's just... I don't know how he's able to do both. By the way, that's maybe someone like him, because he has to do that, he has to text you that. Like he's got to keep everything moving all the time, because if he doesn't, then the bottom drops out and then he's in the corner in the fetal position in tears. And that's what I want to see. And I want...
我也是，我也想看到杰克·塔珀痛哭，但在演播室里，在镜头前，我想看到它。你希望它很棒？对。是的。你会看到他的睫毛膏都花了。哦，天哪。没多少人知道他涂厚重的眼线。
Same here, I want to see Jake Tapper in tears, but in the studio, on camera, I want to see it. You want it to be great? Yeah. Yeah. And you'd see all of his mascara running. Oh my God. Not a lot of people know he wears heavy eyeliner.
他涂了很多睫毛膏。而且假睫毛也是假的。是吗？那是他在化妆椅上度过的大部分时间。他一直在粘假睫毛。好吧，它们让他的眼睛显得很有神。我得这么说。
He wears a lot of mascara. And good friend of his. And the eyelashes are fake too. Are they? That's the majority of his time in the makeup chair. He's gluing on the eyelashes. Well, they make his eyes pop. I'll say that.
它们确实让他的眼睛显得很有神。不过这真是一份好工作。真是一份好工作。他的整个妆容都很棒。我想人们会把那称为……哦，不。我来了。瞧。
They really make his eyes pop. What a gig though. What a gig. His whole like makeup is great. I guess one would refer to that as the... Uh-oh. Here I come. Viola.
不。瞧。等一下。你知道吗？我敢肯定你戴着面具。我戴着面具。我已经戴了六次面具了，我也拒绝那个。我告诉你，那个……
No. Viola. Hang on. You know what? I'm pretty sure you're wearing a mask. I'm wearing a mask. I've been wearing a mask for six times and I refuse that too. I tell you, the one...
你已经用过那个了吗？你用过了。你在采访中确实用过一个，也许我们现在可以重新审视一下。我用了。是的。关于你的国籍。是的，但我不是双重国籍。我是个双性恋者（Bayee）。
Do you use that one already? You did. You did use one in the interview that maybe we can revisit now. I did. Yeah. About your citizenship. Yeah, but I'm not a dual citizenship. I'm a Bayee.
你已经用过那个了吗？是的，你用过。你在采访中确实用过一个，我们现在也许可以重新谈谈。是的，我用过。关于你的国籍。是的，但我不是双重国籍。我是巴耶人。
Bayeeeee. Citizen. Bayeeeeeeee. Smart. Right. Smart. Right. Right.
再见。公民。再见。聪明。对。聪明。对。对。
Right. Right. Right. Right. Right. Right. Right. Right. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。